The company that
brought you Google Glass,
the Google self-driving car,
some of the craziest science fiction
things that you can possibly imagine
is focused on
counting strawberries.
And here's why.
For the last decade or so,
Google X has been designed
to sort of go for these
so-called moonshot projects.
Many of these things
have not panned out.
But there have been a few successes.
What's happened over the years
is that Google X has gone
to being much more pedestrian,
but also real businesses.
And I think that's where
Project Mineral comes in.
Mineral is working on a project
to basically bring robotics
and machine learning
and computer vision,
but to the world of agriculture.
They're building
these things called rovers,
which are semi-autonomous,
remote-controlled robots.
When it drives over these crop
rows, it's taking pictures.
And those pictures are then
being fed into these
very sophisticated
machine learning algorithms.
How many strawberries
does this plant have?
How many leaves does it have?
How tall is it?
What species is it?
And it's trying to use that
data to help farmers say,
with some certainty, which plants
are doing well and which ones aren't.
So the end goal here,
it's one, is to create a business that
that generates revenue where
they are able to sell machine learning
and the robotics expertise
that they have to agriculture companies.
Beyond that, I think the goal
is to do farming better
and in particular to help
farmers do more with less.
And when you talk to people at X,
what they say is
climate change is increasingly
a huge part of their work.
And you can see the
possible impact here.
If farmers are able to
develop better plants that can deal
with rising temperatures,
if they're able to use less water,
less fertilizer,
that could have a significant
climate impact and it could
allow us to live better lives.